so the term fake news has been very much
weaponized by the current administration
and very often when they say that
something is fake news it's not actually
fake news it's just news they don't like
or news that paints the administration
in a negative light but we have some
actual fake news that was repeated and
parroted by the administration and even
some right-wing media outlets that
turned out to be as the name actually
suggests completely and totally false
and it relates to an agreement or more
specifically pieces of an agreement that
supposedly are part of a Mexican
agreement that Donald Trump has reached
and before I even tell you what was said
and what's true and what's not true one
of the worst things that a country can
do geopolitically is to make itself not
trustworthy when other countries can't
trust you in the big picture sense I'm
not talking about intelligence gathering
and the reality that many countries have
you know intelligence operatives are
within a country that are clandestine
I'm not talking about that I'm saying
when other countries can't trust you to
even stick to the deals that you make
with them can't trust you to simply tell
the truth about what you've agreed to do
with them you become toxic on the world
stage and that's what Donald Trump has
become one big example being the Iran
deal
President Obama forged forward with the
Iran deal the Iran nuclear deal Donald
Trump didn't like it but when Donald
Trump took over as president Iran had
not violated any elements of the Iran
deal so when Donald Trump comes in and
says I never liked that deal we're just
backing out of it immediately the United
States loses credibility not just with
Iran which maybe many Americans don't
care about but with the entire world
community in terms of being a country
that other countries can have the
confidence will stick to agreements that
they sign even when the next guy or gal
is in the White House so that was a
horrible example of the ways in which
the Trump administration simply cannot
be trusted but now we have something
that's also horrible which is that it
appears that Donald Trump completely
made-up elements that supposedly had
been reached as part of a deal with
Mexico all meant to show how smart and
strong and a great
negotiator Donald Trump is think back to
a couple of weeks ago when Donald Trump
announced on Twitter those absurd
tariffs on Mexico which would make
things more expensive for everyday
Americans and Trump said at the time the
goal of those tariffs was to get Mexico
to do what he wants on immigration to
finally stop people from coming to the
United States from Mexico illegally
including from points further south of
Mexico and Donald Trump said that the
tariffs were meant to sort of push
Mexico into compliance with what Donald
Trump wants except that if the tariffs
actually succeeded in hurting Mexico it
would cause more people to want to come
to the United States which is exactly
the opposite of what Donald Trump
claimed that he wanted so we explained
how those tariffs made no sense three
days ago
Donald Trump announces he's made a big
deal with Mexico
Trump won Trump was right his threat of
tariffs worked and Mexico has agreed to
do all the stuff that Donald Trump wants
them to do except it appears that Donald
Trump was lying at least about part of
it check out all of the things that
Donald Trump tweeted about this many of
which Mexican Foreign Secretary Marcelo
abroad now says are not true Donald
Trump tweeted quote Mexico has agreed to
immediately begin buying large
quantities of agricultural product from
our great Patriot farmers Mexico says
not true the Mexican foreign secretary
we do not have a specific agreement on
products of that nature period full stop
Trump's line Monday Donald Trump claimed
it was all done because of the tariffs
and because of the relationship that we
have with Mexico also completely untrue
it appears as though according to the
Mexican Foreign Secretary only two
actions were agreed upon on Friday
publicly there's nothing else and one of
those was actually already previously
agreed to and isn't even a new thing
it's not clear that Donald Trump knows
that the Mexican foreign secretary
Marcelo Abroad's saying quote there is
no other thing beyond what I have
explained they wanted something else
totally different to be signed but that
is what there is here there is no other
thing referring to Donald Trump's sort
of implication that there are unwritten
elements of this deal as well Mexican
authorities saying this is it there are
two things that are part of this deal
number one a commitment from Mexico to
deploy its National Guard to the
country's southern border with Guatemala
now it's hilarious that that's even
considered an accomplishment by Trump
because Mexico already had agreed to do
that before Donald Trump even started
the tariff threat understand that that's
something Mexico had already agreed to
do number two that's part of this deal
is that Mexico will now publicly support
the expansion of a program where some
asylum seekers will go back to Mexico
while their cases are being adjudicated
or processed by the American immigration
system that has already been going on
quietly okay understand that 11,000
Mexicans have already gone back to
Mexico under this action or agreement by
Mexico Mexico is now just publicly going
to support the expansion of that program
so understand the absurdity of what's
going on here publicly Donald Trump
claims that there are things in the deal
which just aren't part of the deal
he gets publicly debunked by Mexican
officials when we look at what's
actually in the deal there are two
things in the deal one of which was
already previously announced that's not
cleared from knows that and thinks it
might actually be a bonafide
accomplishment the other is something
that Mexico has already quietly been
doing but now they're going to publicly
support expanding this is total fake
news this is how it all develops and
it's really important to understand the
process Trump tweets about it the Trump
sycophants and followers go crazy
promoting it and claiming victory on the
basis of Donald Trump's tweets and then
we find out oh Mexico says like almost
none of that stuff is true and the stuff
that is true isn't new so media outlets
go to the White House for comment they
say Trump tweeted this and here's what
the Mexican authorities say and here's
what the records say
that we've been able to find and the
White House simply doesn't comment and
meanwhile most trumpets will never hear
about the fact that this was faked and
concocted it remains the truth in the
minds of trumpets that Donald Trump has
actually accomplished this when he has
not it's sad but it's dangerous it's
weaponized ignorant its weaponized low
information and on the world stage it
makes us look extraordinarily childish
and like we can't be trusted
which under Donald Trump we actually
can't be trusted and that's the most
important takeaway in terms of the
effect of this stuff on geopolitics the
short term I guess will be resolved like
eventually there will be some seeing
eye-to-eye between the u.s. and Mexico
about what is and isn't in the deal and
we'll probably look more like what
Mexico thinks is in the deal than what
Donald Trump thinks or claims is in the
deal but the irreversible or at least a
very difficult to reverse problem that's
caused here is the national
embarrassment that is the United States
seen as dishonest the United States not
being seen as even a remotely reliable
negotiating partner that is been
precipitated significantly under the
current president